Hello Everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Resident Evil 2 (Remake)
Now, we're in the basement of some sewer, somewhere, in a place SO labyrinthine
That I don't fully understand exactly where I am or where I'm going
BUT! (inhales loudly) I have been making progress, because I do have a rook.
Now, I don't know what the rook is to or if I can solve the puzzle with the rook
Because I think there's still some queen here that I need to get before I can actually finish this.
(Loud Inhale x2)
So..Or maybe there's even two, 'cause I know there's definitely one, but I don't know if there's not two.
Unless I just grabbed that one, did I just grab the one, I think I just grabbed the one unless that wasn't the one and there was something else,
then I gotta go back up anyway because I got the key with the label on it anyway, so I'm gonna go do that.
And that's all I know for now.
OKAY. Makes sense? Alright we're gonna-
(unintelligble noises)
Just gonna forget about it, just gonna forget about it
I need to get out of here